as you know usually i come out from
behind the curtain and
hello and we get started that way but uh
we're doing it differently tonight
because once again this happens every
now and then
uh during covet we uh we find a guest
who
wants to come here to the theater to the
largo theater
very funny comedian ron funches is
joining us we like ron he's a good guy i
love ron
love ron uh wonderful guy he'll be
joining us
and i like it when people are able to
come here
in person it's it's like a treat it's
like a special
fun day like oh another human yes
a human we haven't been staring at or
living with for a year
right because it's basically been me
andy
a very small skeleton crew jeff ross
sona how are you
oh she's eating her sandwich that's why
sandwich
sona's having a hard time speaking
because i just uh
talked to her and she's got a mouthful
of sandwich a little interesting side
note
uh sona got herself a sandwich didn't
ask me if i wanted
anything you weren't gonna want it yes i
was i'm hungry i would have loved a
sandwich
i wanted a sandwich and you didn't even
ask me
unbelievable i think i think we're this
pandemic has gone on too long
it's got i feel like the light is at the
end of the tunnel and we've
this has got to end right it's it's more
like a dinner party and the guests want
to leave
yeah yeah like it's gotten weird we
won't wait for dessert we'll
just go we'll just go